hey I see here week after week but you
never sing me no I couldn't
I'm not some pop star super senior and
just me well maybe that's what the world
needs to see you know it takes a hero to
express themselves I don't know one
alright you might be surprised you take
this a little courage
[Music]
this is for you dad wherever you are
I love love because they keep me safe we
must respect them because my dad is one
yes my dad is a police and he's Noble
and brave and if my grades are good
enough he lets me drive his truck
oh wise mother especially my dad Donald
Trump is my king I want to
[Music]
[Applause]
well I shouldn't give her that beer
you